[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
PROFESSOR: So we've been
talking about P and NP and time
complexity classes.
And today we're
going to shift gear.
We're going to talk about
space complexity or memory
complexity, as space complexity
is what complexity theorists
usually refer to it as.
And time and space are the
two basic most basic measures
of complexity that we consider.
And so today we're going to
look at the second of those two,
the space complexity.
A lot of this is going to
be by analogy with what
we did for time complexity.
We're going to define
complexity classes.
We'll talk about
polynomial space
and nondeterministic
polynomial space,
see how those classes connect
up with the time complexity
classes that we've
already defined.
And we'll do some examples
that will be setting us up
for our further discussion about
space complexity next week.
So we're going to
talk about, first
of all, what it means
for a Turing machine
to run in a certain
amount of space.
And that's simply going to be
counting the number of cells
that the Turing machine
scans over on its tape
during the course
of its computation.
It might be reading that cell.
It might be writing
on that cell.
But the total number of cells
that it actually visits--
of course, visiting the
same cell multiple times
only counts once because
space can be reused.
But we're going to count
the number of cells
that the Turing machine
visits during the course
of its computation, and
then define the space
utilization by analogy
with what we did for time.
So we'll say a
Turing machine runs
in a certain amount of space--
f of n, we'll say.
First of all, it has to always
hold, so all of the machines
are deciders.
And it uses at most
that much tape--
it visits that number of cells--
on all inputs of length n.
So just like we said
for time complexity,
the machine has to
run within t of n time
on all inputs of
length n, here it's
going to have to use
at most f of n cells
on all inputs of length
n in order for it
to be running in space f of n.
A tape cell is simply a
little square of the tape
where you can write a symbol--
answering a question,
that good question
that came in from the chat.
So I'm not sure we I have
the diagram for that.
And each of the little
squares on the tape
are going to be the tape cells.
Generally, we're going to be
sticking to one-tape Turing
machines.
But I'll make a brief remark
about multi-tape Turing
machines shortly.
Better?
Tape cells, sorry, on
all inputs of length n.
So that's for deterministic
Turing machines.
For nondeterministic
Turing machines,
we will say that it also runs
in a certain amount of space.
So for a
nondeterministic machine,
it has to use at most that
many tape cells on each branch
of its computation separately.
You don't add up
the total number
of cells used across
all of the branches,
just like we don't add up
the total amount of time
the machine uses across
all of its branches.
For the machine to be running
in, say, space n squared,
it has to be using at most
n squared cells or order n
squared cells on each one of
its nondeterministic branches
separately.
There might be exponentially
many branches, but that's OK.
But on each branch, it's going
to be using at most n squared
or order n squared cells.
Importantly, though,
that still the machine
has to be a decider.
It's not enough to be
looping forever and using
a small amount of space.
It could do that,
but that's not going
to count toward the machine
contributing to its space
complexity of that language.
So for the machine to be running
in a certain amount of space,
we say that the machine
holds on all of its branches.
And each one of its branches
uses at most that much space.
I can see lots of typos here.
Thank you.
Why did I mess
this all up today?
So nondeterministic--
good, thank you.
All right, so we're going to
define the space complexity
classes analogous to this
time complexity classes.
So these are languages that
you can do with machines that
run within that space bound.
So space f of n-- you can
think of space n squared--
is all of the languages that a
deterministic one-tape Turing
machine can do within--
can decide within-- by using
at most n squared tape cells,
order n squared tape cells.
Similarly, the nondeterministic
space complexity class
are all of the languages that
a nondeterministic one-tape
Turing machine can
decide, running
within that amount of space.
And lastly, we have
polynomial space.
So that's the union over
all polynomial space bounds
of the space complexity class,
and nondeterministic polynomial
space--
the same for all of the
nondeterministic polynomial
space classes.
So I think I do have
a check-in on this
which talks about
multi-tape Turing machines.
So we can define
space complexity
for multi-tape
Turing machines, just
as we did for one-tape
Turing machines,
and then define the associated
space complexity classes,
and then define
the class P space.
But that would be for
multi-tape Turing machines.
Now for time, remember
that the class
P that you would get for
multi-tape Turing machines is
exactly the same as the class P
that we got for one-tape Turing
machines.
That was part of the
nice quality of the class
P. It's robust in that
sense, and natural.
So how about for PSPACE?
What do you think?
Do we get the same class?
No?
Maybe?
Or yes, because we can convert
a multi-tape Turing machine
to a single-tape
Turing machine, by only
squaring the amount of space?
That was what happened
with time, as you remember.
Or maybe we can do even better.
Converting a multi-tape Turing
machine to single-tape only
increases it by less-- by,
say, a constant factor.
Here, remember,
this is how we're
defining space complexity for
multi-tape Turing machines.
We're taking the sum of all the
cells used on all of the tapes.
All right, so let's launch that
poll and see what you think.
Hopefully, this is not too hard.
Yeah, I think most of you
have got the idea, though.
Some of you are--
I worry sometimes about some
of the answers that I get.
I don't know if you're
serious, or you're really
badly confused.
But anyway, let's wrap this up--
another 10 seconds or so.
Last call.
I'm going to end it.
Yeah, I mean, I think answer
B is a reasonable answer.
In fact, answer C is
the correct answer.
If you just look at the same
simulation from multi-tape
to single-tape and how much
space overhead that simulation
introduces, it's only linear.
You're basically just
taking all of the tapes
of the multi-tape
machine and writing them
down next to one another,
obviously ignoring
all the infinitely many blanks.
We're just taking the
active portion of the tapes,
writing them down
next to each other.
So the total amount
used is just going
to be the sum on the
single-tape of what
was used on each of the
individual multi-tapes
in the original machine.
So there is just a
linear cost overhead
by converting from
multi-tape to single-tape
when you're looking at space,
the amount of memory that's
used.
For time, remember there
was some additional overhead
because we had to be updating
where the virtual heads were.
And that cost extra time to
move our single head around
to do that.
But for space, the amount
of time that's introduced
is irrelevant.
We're only looking at
the amount of memory.
And so that's a--
the overhead on
that is very low.
I do worry about the folks who
are answering A, for example,
for this question.
You should be rethinking
what's really going on here.
Now let us move on here
from that to our next slide
and compare the time and
space complexity classes.
Time and space complexity-- how
do they relate to one another?
And so first of all,
we're going to point out--
let's start out--
here, t of n is
going to be
representing some bound,
either on the time or
the amount of space.
And generally, at least
up until this point,
and mostly going
forward, though there's
going to be one variation
on that a little later,
but we're going to be
focusing on bounds which
are at least big enough
to either read the input
or at least hold the input.
So that's why we refer to
t of n being at least n.
So now if we look at the time
complexity class t of n--
think of-- t of n
typically would be, say,
n squared, maybe.
And the things that
you can do in n
squared time I claim you can
also do in n squared space.
And basically, it's just
using the very same machine.
Suppose you have a machine
that runs in n squared time.
How could it possibly
use, say, n squared--
n cubed-- space, if it's
running only in n squared time?
Even if it tries to use as
much tape as it possibly could,
as many tape cells
as it possibly could,
and sending its
head cruising out
into the blank portion of the
tape, chewing up as much--
as many tape cells
as it possibly can--
in n squared time,
it's only going
to be able to use
n squared space.
So the very same machine
that runs in t of n time
is also going to
run in t of n space.
So this containment
here follows really
without doing any work at all.
So just restating that here, a
Turing machine that runs in t
of n steps cannot use more
than t of n tape cells.
So right now,
we're focusing on--
we could prove some
analogous statements
about nondeterministic
complexity,
but let's focus here on the
deterministic complexity.
Now let's look at going
the other direction.
Suppose we have a Turing machine
that uses t of n space now.
Does that immediately imply
it's using only t of n time?
And that's not so clear and,
in fact, probably not true,
because space appears to be
much more powerful than time.
And within a certain
amount of space,
you can run for much longer
than that same amount of time.
So how long could you run?
So what you can show is that if
you're running within a certain
amount of space-- t of
n space, let's say--
n squared space, for example.
The amount of time
you could use is
going to be exponential in n
squared, a 2 to the order n
squared.
Sometimes we also write that
as the union of c to the n
squared by pulling down
that constant here.
Well, it's also
just to understand
what we mean by order t
of n up in the exponent.
It means the union over c
to the t of n for all c.
Either of these are just
completely equivalent,
so whichever one you're
more comfortable with.
But why is this
going to be true?
Why does a Turing machine that
runs in, say, n squared space,
use at most 2 to the
order n squared time?
And that's because
if you look at how
many possible configurations
the machine can have,
remember that a
configuration is essentially
the contents of the tape.
There's also the head
position and the state.
But the dominant aspect of
a configuration is the tape.
And so how many different
tape contents can you have?
Well, it's going to be
exponential in the length
of that tape because each
cell can have some fixed
number of symbols in it.
If a machine repeats
a configuration,
it's going to go
forever, which we're
forbidding in these
machines, because they're all
going to be deciders.
So they can only run
for an amount of time
which is bounded by the
number of configurations
that the machine can have.
And so the machine can have--
if it's running in t of
n space, then the amount
of time that it
could be running is
going to be at most some
constant to the t of n or 2
to the order of t of n,
saying the same thing,
unless it's going to
repeat a configuration
and end up looping.
So these are the two
fundamental connections
between time and space.
Time is contained within
the same amount of space.
Space is contained within that
amount of time exponentiated.
So one corollary of
that is that the class P
is contained within PSPACE.
Similarly, NP is going to
be contained within NPSPACE
for the very same reason.
Is this understandable?
This is a good place or
a moment to add one more
line to tell you about.
But leading into the next slide,
we're-- so if you understand
the definitions of what
we've done so far, all of--
this is a fairly
straightforward theorem,
and the corollary is immediate.
So anything that you
can do in n squared time
you can do in n
squared in space.
And so anything you can
do in polynomial time
you can also do in
polynomial space.
Yeah, c-- somebody's
asking me, what is the c?
c is essentially going to be
the size of the tape alphabet
because that's going to
govern how many different
configurations you have.
There's a slight extra
factor for the tape--
the head location
and also the state.
But the main thing is going to
be the number of tape symbols
and the length of the tape.
But what's going to
come next is we're
going to prove something more
powerful than this corollary
that P is contained in
PSPACE, because not only is P
contained in PSPACE, but NP
is also contained in PSPACE.
And for that, we're going
to have to do more work.
So somebody's asking me
about the number of states.
The number of states
is going to be--
is fixed depending
on the machine only.
So it doesn't depend upon n.
So it could at most affect
the number of configurations
by a constant factor.
And those constant
factors are going
to be absorbed within the
definitions of these complexity
classes because that's how
we define them to be ignoring
the constant factors.
Why don't we just take a--
this may be a good place
to pause for a second
and see if there's any
questions, because I
think for some of you, this
may be straightforward.
But I think it's less
common to be measuring--
thinking about the amount of
memory as a complexity measure.
So this is perhaps a
little less familiar.
Some of you have seen measuring
time in other classes,
but measuring the
amount of space
that the algorithm uses probably
is a little less familiar.
And maybe it's worth spending
a moment or two answering
questions about that.
So I'm not sure I understand
the question that just came in,
but I'll read it out there.
Is it possible that a Turing
machine can loop forever?
Absolutely.
But a Turing machine
that loops forever
does not count as one that
runs within the space bound.
To run within the space
bound, the machine
must halt on every input.
It has to be a decider.
We're only considering
deciders here.
So is it possible a Turing
machine could loop forever?
Yes.
Isn't the Turing
machine we're talking
about a member of space,
and thus a decider?
Not totally sure I
understand the question.
But if a Turing machine is
not halting on all inputs,
it's not a decider.
That's our definition.
Are we good?
We're not getting very
many questions here.
So I'm assuming
you're all with me
or so lost you don't even know
what to ask, which is not good.
So be bold.
If you're confused, throw
a question out there,
because I don't want to
race through this lecture,
since it's maybe a little
less familiar to some of you.
So let's move on.
As promised, I'm going to show
you now that NP, not only P,
as happens immediately,
but NP is contained
as a subset of a PSPACE.
So that is--
I did get a question.
I moved on before I
answered this question.
Can I explain part two
of the proof again?
Part two?
OK, let's just do it.
If something runs in a
certain amount of space,
you have to just think about how
many different configurations
the machine can have within
that amount of space.
Remember the configurations that
we defined way back at LBAs?
So the number of
configurations of the machine
can have depends on how
much space it's allocated.
Like the LBAs-- they had a
fixed number of configurations,
and we gave a
calculation for that,
which is basically
an exponential
in the amount of space.
That's how many configurations
the machine can have.
So if the machine is not
looping, if it's a decider,
it can never repeat
a configuration.
And that's going to tell us how
long the machine can possibly
run for.
It's important to understand.
I'm not sure if
I knew how to say
that in any way that different
from what I said before.
OK, getting back now to proving
that NP is a subset of PSPACE.
So now we're going to have
to do something that's
in a way different from what
we did on the previous slide,
because now it's not
going to be enough to work
with the same machine.
Before when we were
converting, we're
showing that a certain
amount of time, time class,
is contained within
a space class
by virtue of the
very same machine--
by just showing
that if it's running
within a certain
amount of time, then it
has to be running within
that same amount of space.
Or in terms of the
space, it was in the--
given a certain
amount of space, it
has to be running that same
machine within a certain amount
of time.
Here we're going to--
mixing non-determinism
and determinism.
So we're going to have to take
a machine that's an NP type
machine, a nondeterministic
polynomial time machine,
and convert it into a
deterministic machine that
doesn't use a
whole lot of space.
So there's a difference in
the character of this theorem
because we have to
introduce a new machine.
And the way we're going
to prove that, I'm
going to take advantage
of some of the things
we've already shown
to prove this.
One could also prove it a
little bit more directly.
And maybe it's worth making
sure you understand both proofs.
So the first thing
I'm going to observe
is that SAT, our
NP-complete language,
the satisfiability language,
itself is a member of PSPACE.
And the reason for that is
when you're given a formula,
and now you want to test if
that formula is satisfiable,
one way to do it, the
most obvious way to do it,
is try all assignments one
by one and see if any of them
satisfy the formula.
Now that's going to
take a lot of time.
But how much space does it use?
I have in mind reusing
the space every time
we try the next assignment.
Think of going through all
of the assignments the way
an odometer would work--
just trying every
possible assignment,
but reusing the
space where you're
going to write that
assignment down,
incrementing it like a number
written in binary, if you wish.
Going through all the possible
assignments, every time
you get in the next assignment,
you plug it into the formula
and see if the
formula's satisfied.
If it is, then you can
accept immediately.
If not, you go on to
the next assignment.
And only when you've gone
through all the assignments
in that way, and none of them
have satisfied the formula,
then you can reject.
So how much space does that use?
That doesn't use a
whole lot of space
because you're reusing
the space to write down
one assignment after the next.
It's only going to be using
an amount of space which
is big enough to hold an
assignment, which is basically
linear, because it's the size
of the number of variables
of the formula.
So that's going to be a linear
amount of space to solve
the satisfiability problem.
And so the
satisfiability problem
is certainly in PSPACE--
step one.
Step two is we're going
to take advantage of what
we know about reducibility.
So if A is polynomial
time reducible to B,
we've already commented--
we didn't say this exactly
in this way.
But it's still going to
follow that anything you
can do in a certain
amount of time,
you can also do in
that amount of space,
because it's the
very same machine--
can't use any more space
than the amount of time
it was allocated.
So if A is polynomial
time reducible to B,
it's also going to be
reducible in polynomial space.
A polynomial space machine
could do the reduction.
So that means if A is
polynomial time reducible to B,
and B is in
polynomial space, then
A is also in polynomial space.
But we know, because
satisfiability is NP-complete,
that every language of
NP is reducible to SAT.
So put SAT in place
of B. Every NP
language is polynomial
time-reducible to SAT.
And we now know that
SAT is in PSPACE.
So therefore, every
language in NP
is in PSPACE because
they're all polynomial time
reducible to SAT.
So just by using some
of the technology
we've developed, namely
the notion of completeness
shows some of its power, that if
you want to conclude something
about an entire class, an
entire complexity class,
if you have a complete problem
for that complexity class,
often it's enough just to work
with the complete problem.
And then everything else by
virtue of the reducibility,
is going to inherit
the same property.
Doesn't work in all cases,
but in many of the cases,
as long as the reducibility
can be computed
by the type of procedure
you're working with,
then you can-- then it follows.
You could also prove
this more directly.
I think it's in some
ways a little clumsy
or a little bit less elegant.
But you can say, well,
let me just take my--
take a language that's in NP.
It has a nondeterministic
polynomial time algorithm.
And then give a deterministic
polynomial space algorithm--
simulates that NP algorithm
just by going through all
the different branches,
but making sure
that going through all
those different branches,
you're reusing the space and
not using new space every time
you're going through
a different branch.
And you can arrange things
if you're just a little bit
careful to do it that way.
So you could give
a direct simulation
in polynomial space of
any NP Turing machine.
So I mean, that's also
completely satisfactory.
But I think this is a
little more elegant.
This furthermore
is going to allow
us to conclude some additional
languages are in PSPACE.
Let's define a class we have not
yet seen, though maybe you've
seen this--
I think we've talked about
this notion of co before.
I think we talked about
co-Turing-recognizable.
Those are the class of
languages whose complements
are Turing-recognizable,
and the same for co and P.
This is the class of languages
whose complements are in NP.
If you take the complement of
every language that's in NP,
and now you got
all the languages
that are in this class coNP.
It's complement of NP.
So for example, the complement
of the HAMPATH problem.
So all the graphs which don't
have Hamiltonian paths from
SAT, so the
non-Hamiltonian graph--
the non-Hamiltonian
path problem--
that's a coNP problem.
Or here's a language
we haven't--
I'm not going to define as
in terms of its complement--
the tautology problem.
These are the formulas
where all assignments
satisfy the formula.
All assignments make
the formula true.
So a tautology is a
statement that's always true,
no matter how you
plug in the variables.
So the tautology
language is in coNP
because its complement, which
is the non-tautologies-- those
are the formulas for which
there's some assignment which
makes it false.
So that's going to be
clearly an NP language.
So tautology is a coNP language.
Now one thing that
we get immediately
from the theorem
as a corollary--
really should write
this as a corollary--
is that coNP is also a subset of
PSPACE And the reason for that
is--
and this is something that--
it's, again, easy,
but make sure you
understand it-- is
that PSPACE itself
is closed under complement
because it is defined in terms
of deterministic machines.
And deterministic machines--
you can always flip the answer
and get a machine of the
same type which will decide
the complementary language.
So for deterministic machines--
deterministic deciders,
I should say--
you can always flip the answer.
Now, so here, we have
anything that's in PSPACE.
It has a deterministic
polynomial time--
polynomial space-- machine.
And so its
complementary language
is also going to be in PSPACE.
So PSPACE and
coPSPACE are equal.
And so that's why coNP is
going to be in PSPACE--
going to be a subset of PSPACE.
I hope that's not
getting mixed up
by all of the different
alphabet soup here.
But here is maybe
a picture maybe
that'll be helpful of
how the world looks
for the time and space
complexity classes so far.
So we have P is a subset of NP.
It's also a subset of coNP,
again, for the same reason
that P and coP are equal.
We never even really talk about
coP because it's the same as P.
But NP and coNP--
those are two classes
where we don't
know whether they're equal or
not, because an NP machine--
you can't necessarily complement
the behavior of an NP machine
and end up with an NP machine.
So a question here--
how do we know
that coNP is a complete
class of problems?
I didn't say that there's
anything about completeness.
And coNP is just a
collection of languages.
I'm not saying it's any--
any particular feature about it.
In fact, it does have
a complete problem,
just like NP has a
complete problem.
The complements--
and I'm not going
to prove this right here, though
it's pretty straightforward.
Complements of all the
NP-complete languages
are going to be
coNP-complete languages.
I will answer some
of the questions
about possible alternate worlds.
This is how we believe
the world looks like,
with each one of these regions
being separated from one
another, including this little
corner of the world here,
NP, and intersect
coNP, which is not--
there might be languages
in here which are not in P.
And we actually believe
there are such languages.
But again, all of
this is conjectural.
And even whether P and PSPACE
are the same or different
is an open question.
We don't even know
the answer to that,
which is perhaps even
more shocking that we
don't know how to solve P and--
prove P different
from NP, that we
don't know how to prove P
different from PSPACE, which
seems to be a much bigger class.
It would be incredible
that anything
you can do with a
polynomial amount of space
you can also do with a
polynomial amount of time.
But don't know
how to prove that.
They're different.
And in fact, so this is
how the world could look.
Everything could collapse down.
P could equal PSPACE.
And then all of these
classes would be the same.
And I should also mention--
I don't have this
as another diagram
here, but just to answer--
there's other possibilities.
For example, P could equal NP
without being equal to PSPACE.
And then you'd have a
different-looking Venn diagram
here, where there'd
be just two classes.
P, NP and coNP would
all be the same.
PSPACE would be different.
That's possible.
At least we have no idea.
A lot of these things can
collapse in various ways.
And you just have
to make sure that--
there are some collapses
that obviously could not
occur, like P--
if P equals NP, it's
also going to equal coNP.
So you can't get--
there are obviously
some crazy collapses
which could not happen--
that P collapsing-- P
and NP being the same,
but different from coNP.
That can't happen.
But avoiding some obvious
contradictory situations,
everything else is possible.
So somebody said--
so here's a question.
Let me just answer
a few of these.
Did we use the
completeness of coNP
to show that coNP is
a subset of coPSPACE?
No, we didn't do it that way.
We showed that coNP--
well, let's see.
Did we?
Is that fair?
Well, I suppose.
NP of subset of
PSPACE immediately
implies, because you're
complementing both sides,
that coNP is a
subset of coPSPACE.
So you don't have to deal
with the complete problems
on the other side.
That's too complicated
to get into here.
You don't need to talk about
coNP-complete problems.
Though, again, those
are very simple to get
from NP-complete problems.
Let's see what else is here.
Are there NP-complete
problems that are in coNP?
So the answer to that is, no,
not as far as-- well, I mean,
there would be-- if there was
an NP-complete problem in coNP,
then all of NP would be in
coNP, and they would be equal.
So we suspect the NP-complete
problems are not in coNP,
but don't know
how to prove that.
So why is tautology in coNP?
So here is-- tautology
sits in this class, here.
The reason is that its
complementary language
is in NP.
The complement of
tautology are the languages
where there is some assignment
which makes the formula false.
So with an NP machine, you
can just guess that assignment
and check that it makes
the formula false.
So the complement of
tautology is an NP language.
And so tautology
is a coNP language.
So somebody's asking
about PSPACE and NPSPACE.
And how do those
relate to one another?
So that's looking
ahead to what we're
going to be doing next week,
but I'll give you a preview.
An old, but at the
time surprising,
theorem was that PSPACE and
NPSPACE actually are equal.
So they had this analogy
where time breaks down.
So polynomial space and
non-deterministic polynomial
space do turn out to be equal.
The most obvious
way of proving--
of trying to simulate
an an NPSPACE machine
would be give you an exponential
deterministic space algorithm.
So we'll go through that.
But there is an
algorithm which collapses
non-deterministic
polynomial space down
to deterministic polynomial
space, which, again,
at the time was
kind of surprising.
Last question I'll take--
is there some equivalent
concept to the idea
of a certificate for coNP?
Yes, there is a notion
of a certificate.
But now it's going to be a
certificate that you're not
in the language instead
of a certificate
that you're in the
language, and then, again,
work for the very same reason
that we have certificates
for NP languages, where you
had certificate for membership.
For coNP, you have certificate
for non-membership.
There's no other certificate
for membership in coNP.
So let's move on.
So now we're going
to introduce--
we're going to look at
some important examples.
These are examples
that we're going to--
I'm going to give you
two examples, first,
one called TQBF.
And then we're going to
have a second example.
Both of those we're going to--
one of them is going to be an
example of a problem in PSPACE.
Then the other one is
going to be an example
of a problem in NPSPACE.
And these are going to be
important languages for us.
So they're not just going to
serve as examples for today,
but they're going to be useful
languages for us later on.
So just keep that in mind
as we're going through it.
So to understand TQBF,
you have to understand
what are called quantified
Boolean formulas or QBFs.
So those are Boolean formulas,
just like the ones we've been
seeing-- we've been
talking about--
with Boolean variables and the
ands/ors and negated variables.
But now you're going
to add qualifiers,
the "exists" quantifiers
and "for all" quantifiers.
If you haven't seen
quantifiers, you
need to go back
and review those.
I think that we already
introduced-- talked about them
briefly earlier in the term.
But this is part of the basic
math that you need to know.
Maybe you'll-- not
comfortable with them,
you'll pick it up
somewhat during the course
of today's and the next
few lectures, but anyway.
So if you have a
Boolean formula--
I'll give you some
examples-- that
has "exists" and "for
all" quantifiers,
the requirement
for it to be a QBF
is that all of
the variables have
to be within the scope of
one of the quantifiers.
So all of the variables
of the formula
have to be quantified by
one of the quantifiers.
And we're going to assume the
quantifiers are in front--
are leading quantifiers in front
of the rest of the expression.
So because all of the
variables have been quantified,
then a quantified
Boolean formula
is going to be either
true or false following
the meaning of the quantifiers.
And again, some of
this may become clearer
as we do some examples.
So here are some
examples coming.
So here is one--
here is a QBF.
So all of the variables,
which are just x and y--
they both appear in front of--
next to some quantifier.
So that's going to be-- that's
a requirement if we have a QBF.
And so this says, for
all x, there exists a y.
This expression holds.
So we need to unpack that
and understand what it means.
It says, for every x--
for every way of
assigning a Boolean value
to x, so x is going to
be either true or false,
there exists a way of
assigning a Boolean value for y
to make this true--
to make the rest of the
expression hold true.
And we'll go through that.
But let's contrast that with
the second example, where
I invert the order
of the quantifiers,
because that's going to be
important for the meaning
of the formula.
So if I say for
every x, there is
a y, which makes the rest
of it true, that says,
well, no matter how
I set x, there's
going to be way to set
y to make this true.
So that says, well, if I
set x to true, [AUDIO OUT]
got to be some way to set y to
make the remaining expression
hold.
So if I set x to true,
what should I set y to be?
Well, if I set x to be true,
maybe I could set y to be true.
Well, then this
clause is satisfied,
but this clause
won't be satisfied.
So setting y to be true
is not-- it won't work.
But for every x, I only need
to show there exists some y.
So if I take x to be true,
I can set y to be false.
And now this one
is-- this one holds,
and this one holds,
and the formula holds.
But I have to make
sure that that's
going to be the case
for both settings of x
because I'm saying for all x.
So if I set x now to
false, because I already
showed that it works
for x equal to true,
if I set x equal to false,
if I set now y to be true,
this is going to hold.
So this expression
is true, because it
is the case that for
every way to set x,
there is a way to set y.
So this part holds.
Let's compare that
with this case.
Is there some way to set y such
that no matter how I set x,
this is going to hold?
And that's not going to be true.
No matter what you
pick for y, there
is going to be some way to
set x to make this false.
So does there exist a y such
that every x makes this true?
No.
If you try x equal to true,
it's not going to work.
If you try x equal to false,
So this second phi 2
expression-- quantified QBF--
is false.
We're going to be
playing with these a lot.
So it's important to understand
how this quantification works.
So TQBF is the problem
of testing whether one
of these QBFs is true.
Or phrased as a language, it's
the collection of true QBFs.
And that's where we
get the acronym TQBF--
not acronym, the abbreviation
TQBF for the True Quantified
Boolean Formulas.
So going back to
that example, phi 1
is a true quantified
Boolean formula,
and phi 2 is not a true
quantified Boolean formula.
So that's why phi 1
is in the language.
Phi 2 is not in the language.
Now our computational
problem is to test
whether quantified Boolean
formulas are true or not.
And then we can do it
in polynomial space.
Oh, there's a Check-in first.
I claim that SAT is a
special case of TQBF.
Why is that?
How can we think of
SAT as a special case?
If I give you a SAT
formula, how can I
see that as also a TQBF problem?
If you want to test if
that formula is true,
what would you say?
Remove all the quantifiers
or add some quantifiers?
And what kind of
quantifiers, maybe?
How is SAT, just testing
a formula is satisfiable,
a special case of this--
what I claim is a
more general problem
of solving these TQBF problems?
Closing down.
Last call.
Yes, indeed.
Satisfiability--
so C is correct.
When you're talking about
a satisfiability problem,
you're saying, is there
a satisfying assignment?
Another way of writing that down
is take that Boolean formula
and put "exists" in front
of all the variables.
Does there exist a way to
set x1 and x2 and x3 and x4
to make the formula true--
to make that formula hold?
So SAT is a special case
by aiding exist qualifiers
of a TQBF problem.
So C is correct.
So why is this problem
in PSPACE, as I claimed?
And for that, we're going
to give a simple recursive
algorithm.
In any quantified
Boolean formula--
now, if you want to test
if it's true or not,
we're going to basically strip
off the leading quantifiers.
So if it's an exist
quantifier, we'll
remove it and plug
in true and false
associated to its variable,
and then solve those problems
recursively.
So this is just going to be a
recursive procedure for solving
TQBF problems, operating
by stripping off
the quantifiers in
front and getting
smaller and smaller formulas.
But now we're going
to be plugging
in values, true
and false, instead
of relying on the
quantifier to give us
the meaning of the formula.
So first of all, if
there are no quantifiers,
then there are no variables,
because all variables have to--
bound within quantifiers.
And in that case, that
quantified Boolean formula
has to simply be the statement
true or the statement false.
And so you're going
to output accordingly
because that's all it can
be if you have no variables.
If the formula starts
with an exists quantifier,
what you're going to do--
so here, psi is the
remainder of the formula
after you strip off
that exist quantifier.
So you're going to
evaluate psi now, but take
that variable that was
bound by the exists
and just plug in true
and false respectively.
So you're going to get
two, now, new problems,
and run them and evaluate
them using the same procedure
recursively, but now
with x plugged in for--
true plugged in for x,
and also then with false
plugged in for x--
and get the answers
for those two cases.
And if either one of
them ended up accepting,
then you're going to
accept, because there exists
a value of 4x which makes
the whole thing true,
because you just
recursively showed
that there was such a
value, either true or false,
the thing has accepted.
And if both of them fail,
then you're going to reject.
And the very same idea if you
have a for all quantifier.
You're going to evaluate the
remainder of the formula,
again, with x equal to true and
false, so as two subproblems.
But now you're going
to require them
both to accept because that's
the meaning of for all--
that both assignments to x
have to make the formula true.
So you're going to evaluate
them recursively and accept
if both of them are true, as
determined by your recursive--
your recursion.
So how much space does this use?
I'm not going to go through
this in great detail.
But each recursive level
uses just a constant amount
of space.
So every time you
do a recursion,
you have to remember
that that value--
that assignment
to that variable.
You want to think of
recursion as being
implemented on a stack.
So you're just going to
pop-- push on the stack
that value of that variable,
which is that true or false.
So basically it's
1 bit of memory
that you're going to require
every time you're going down
the recursion.
You just have to remember what--
which case you're working on,
whether x equal to true or x
equal to false.
And so each recursive level
just involves constant space.
And the depth of the recursion--
how much might you
have to remember?
Well, it's going to be at
most 1 for every quantifier,
because that's--
you're stripping
them off as you're
going down the recursion.
So that's going to be at most
the length of the formula.
That's at most the number
of quantifiers you can have.
And so the total amount
of space used by this
is going to be just n, order n.
So this problem is
solved in NSPACE,
and so that's why
it's in PSPACE.
I think that's all I
wanted to say about this.
If we regard the tape
in a Turing machine
as memory in a modern computer,
what does the finite control
correspond to?
The finite control
corresponds to just
a finite additional memory.
The tape is an unlimited
amount of memory.
Or if we're putting
bounds, the amount
of tape is going to be,
say, n squared memory,
where n is the length of m--
n is the length of the input.
So, yeah, they're both memories,
but the finite control is--
it doesn't grow with n.
So that's going to be just
some constant amount of memory.
What would be the time
complexity of this algorithm?
Time complexity would be bad.
It's going to be exponential.
So you'd have to just
double-check that.
But it's going to
be something like 2
to the number of
variables that you have--
2 the number of quantifiers,
plus some small overhead
for evaluating the
formula multiple time.
But it's going to
be exponential.
What else can I answer for you?
So someone is asking,
going back again to coNP,
and how do we know there
exists a problem in coNP that's
coNP-complete?
We didn't define
even what that means.
But coNP-complete
means-- we're going
to start seeing other
examples of completeness
for different
complexity classes.
In particular, one thing that's
going to happen on Tuesday
is we'll see a problem
that's complete for PSPACE.
In fact, it's going to be TQBF.
So looking ahead is going to
be a PSPACE-complete problem.
But we even have
to have the notion
of what we mean by complete
for these other classes.
And in the case of coNP,
a problem is coNP-complete
if it's in coNP, and
every other coNP problem
is polynomial time-reducible
to it, so just exactly
the same as we had for NP,
just plugging in coNP instead.
And you just have to
work through the logic,
but it's pretty straightforward.
The complement of any
NP-complete problem
is going to be a coNP-complete
problem using that definition.
So I don't want to go through
that, those simple steps.
But you just can go and
verify that offline--
that that's going to be true.
And I think we're going to
probably talk about that
later in the semester, too.
So another question-- how
does the TQBF algorithm--
ah, that is a good
question here.
Why is the TQBF algorithm that
I just described in PSPACE?
Doesn't the thing-- every
time I'm doing a recursion,
doesn't things branch
out so that I end up
using exponential space?
Critical thing which I actually
don't think I mentioned,
which I think is
important to observe,
is that when you're doing
those two recursive calls, when
you set x equal to true
and set x equal to false,
after you've determined
the answer for when you set
x equal to true, now
you reuse that space,
that very same space,
to test what happens
when you have x equal to false.
So that's the power
of space, which
makes it different from time,
is that it can be reused.
So after you've got
the answer for when
you have x equal to true,
now you free up that space.
That's no longer needed anymore.
You just remember the answer.
And now you see what happens
when you have x equal to false,
using that same space.
So there's no
exponential blow-up.
That's an important point.
I'm glad you gave me
the chance to say it.
So somebody's asking
about defining
time of a non-deterministic
Turing machine
to the maximum time
of each branch.
Well, that's sort of
what we have done.
Maybe I don't understand
your question.
But you'll have to
ask it afterward
because I don't want to be
delaying any more than we have.
So we're going to go
back and move on, here.
Second example-- and this one
is a kind of a fun example,
but it's also going to be
an important one for us.
It's called the Ladder Problem.
So you may have seen something
called a word ladder.
But in general, a ladder
is a sequence of strings
which are all of
the same length,
but where consecutive strings
differ in a single symbol.
So for example, if you a
word ladder for English,
it's going to be a ladder
where all the words are--
all of the strings
are English words.
So here's an example.
I thought I fixed that.
OK, here is a word
ladder for English.
And maybe you've seen these.
Suppose I want to try to
get from "work" to "play."
But all of the
intermediate strings
should be English words
with four letters that
differ from their previous
one in only a single letter.
And I want to somehow change the
word "work" to the word "play."
So I don't know if you know.
So for example, I can
change "work" to "pork."
So here's just one
letter difference,
which looks like it's an
improvement, because now I
have the--
I'm in agreement on the play.
But sometimes, you
might change it.
You might have a good
change, and then you
have to undo it later, which
I think actually happens here.
So "pork" then is "port."
But then we gave
up that progress.
We made "port" to "sort"
to "suit" to "slot."
You've got to understand
what I'm doing here.
Each case, I'm just
changing a single letter.
But all of these words--
all of these have to be
legitimate English words
of length 4.
"Plot," "ploy,"
and then "play"--
so that's what a word
ladder in English would be.
Of course, you can do it
in different languages.
And now I'm going to
talk about it abstractly,
where instead of having a
natural human language as being
the test for a word--
for being-- a string
being legitimate--
I'm going to define
any old language.
Let's say A is going to be some
language, some set of strings.
And those are going to
be the legal strings that
can be in the ladder.
So ladder A is a
ladder of strings
that are all members of A.
And now the ladder
DFA problem is A going
to be the language of some DFA.
So I'm giving you B and then a
start string and an end string.
So this is like work and play.
U and v are like work and
play, so where B is a DFA.
And its language has a
ladder that goes from u to v,
and here are the
intermediate strings.
All right, so I'm going to
show you that this ladder DFA
problem is an NPSPACE.
This not super hard
because basically--
well, let's just actually
look at the slide here.
The way it's going to work
is it's nondeterministically
going to guess that
sequence from u to v.
So if I'm trying to get from
work to play, imagine those--
I'm going to be
using this in place
of the language of
my finite automaton,
just because this is
easier to talk about.
But imagine these
are being strings
that are accepted by that DFA.
So now I'm trying to get from
my string u to the string v.
And I want to test.
Can I get there by changing
one letter at a time,
but staying at strings that
are accepted by the DFA?
I'm just going to guess that
sequence nondeterministically.
But I have to make sure--
careful of two things.
I don't want to guess the
sequence all in advance
because that sequence might
be exponentially long.
You have to calculate how
long it could possibly be.
But you might change
to one symbol,
then change it to
a different symbol,
then change it back to
that original symbol.
So the only bound that
you can write down
is the number of
possible strings
that you can have
of that length.
So it might be exponential.
You don't want to write
down that whole thing
because that's going to be
exceeding your space bound.
But you don't need to.
You're just going to
guess them one at a time,
forgetting about
the previous one.
So just keep guessing the
next one in the sequence
and only remembering
that one and seeing
if you ever get to the
string-- your target string.
But then when you do that,
you have to make sure
that you don't end
up going forever,
because that's not allowed
in your NPSPACE algorithm.
So you're going to
have to keep a counter
to make sure that if you
go beyond that bound, which
is going to be the
maximum number of strings
you could possibly
have, then you're
going to just shut that branch
of the nondeterminism off.
You're going to just
reject on that branch.
So here is-- I'm
going to write--
say this here.
Here is my nondeterministic
polynomial space procedure.
I'm given my language-- my DFA
B and my start and end strings.
I let y equal to start string.
Write down the
length of my strings
that I'm going to have to keep
in mind all the way through.
And then I'm going to just
repeat the following t
times, where t is the
maximum length this can be,
which is the size of the
alphabet of these things
to the mth power, where m is
the length of those strings.
And I'm just going to
nondeterministically change
one symbol at a time,
making sure that I'm
staying in the language,
so rejecting immediately
if that change introduced a
string outside the language,
and accepting if
that string that I
get by changing that single
symbol is now my target.
And if I've gone
through my bound,
and I haven't managed
to reach that target,
then I'm just going to reject.
And we just have to observe
that this algorithm doesn't
use too much space.
So if you imagine
what we need here,
here's my input, u and
v, which is a blanked n,
and the total amount of space.
I just have to
remember the current y
and also my counter
t, my counter up to t.
So each of those can be written
down essentially in space.
So the total amount is
going to be order n space.
So that shows that this
ladder DFA problem is actually
in nondeterministic space n--
nondeterministic linear space.
And what we're
going to show next
is that this
language is actually
solvable in deterministic space.
And this is perhaps
a bit of a surprise.
So what's the size of the input?
The size of the
input is going to be
what it takes to write down
the DFA and the two strings, u
and v. So here, yeah,
I mean, I should
have also included as part of
the input the description of B
itself.
But that's going to be
more in my favor because--
this is slightly
incorrect, because B
itself has to appear
as part of the input,
so apologies for that.
But still, the
amount of space used
is going to be order n,
because these are going
to be actually less than n.
So we don't run out of
time for the lecture,
we can save additional
questions for afterward.
I'll stick around
for a few minutes.
But I just really have
one more slide here,
and that is proving
this theorem that ladder
can be done deterministically
in polynomial space.
And that's going to be
important as a kind of preview
of what we're going to
be doing on Tuesday.
If this goes a little fast, I'll
go over it again on Tuesday.
So let's just see how it goes.
So I'm going to show the same
ladder DFA problem is solvable
deterministically
in polynomial space.
But this time, it's
going to be n squared
space instead of
nondeterministically
in n space.
So there's going
to be some cost,
but it's only going
to be a squaring.
So remember what the problem is.
I'm giving you
that DFA, and I've
given you two strings in
the language of that DFA.
And I want to know, can I
get from the first string
to the second string by
changing one symbol at a time,
but always making sure that
the strings along the way
are accepted by that DFA?
So I'm going to introduce
notation saying,
can I get from string
u to v by a ladder?
But now I'm limiting how
many steps I can take.
So I'm writing u to
v, but doing it only
within B intermediate
strings, B steps.
So is there a ladder from
u to v of length at most B?
That's what it means to
write this notation down.
So I'm going to give you
a recursive procedure
to solve the bounded ladder
problem, where it's just
like before, but now
I'm going to say,
not only does there
a ladder from u to v,
but there's a ladder
of length at most B.
And that's going to allow
me to solve the ladder
problem recursively by
shrinking the size of B.
So how is this going to work?
Here is going to be the idea.
So here's my u and my
v. And the procedure
is going to work by instead of
nondeterministically guessing
the steps that take
me from work to play,
because I don't have
nondeterminism anymore,
I have to operate
deterministically.
What I'm going to do is work--
instead of going from--
looking at the very first
thing that follows from u,
I'm going to jump
right to the middle
and try every possible
middle string.
I have no clue even what that
middle string should look like,
so I'm going to try all
possibilities in sequence.
Once I have one of
those possibilities,
I'm going to
recursively try to solve
the problem by splitting that.
But I'm now going to divide
that B value in half.
So here is the maximum
value we can have.
This is the t from
the previous slide
which is the maximum length.
Here, I'm going to try
every possible intermediate.
Let's start off with A, all A's.
And now I can cut
the problem in half.
Can I get from work to all
A's and all A's to play?
Well, very first
thing I should check
is making sure that
all A's in fact
is a string in the language.
And if we're thinking
of the language as--
imagining it's like English--
all A's is not a
legitimate word.
So you try the next one, AAB.
And this is how
it's going to work,
but now you're going to be--
instead of using English,
you're going to feed it
into the finite automaton,
just one after the next, trying
every possibility until--
like a clock, like an
odometer, just trying them all,
until eventually you find a
string that's in the language.
I'm representing that by
an English word "able."
Maybe that's the first word
that you would have found.
And then once you find
that, you're going to--
can I get from "work"
to "able" and "able"
to "play" recursively, reusing
the space again, but now
where the bound is cut in half?
So that's the whole algorithm.
So just going
through it quickly,
and I will do this again,
here is my DFA going from u
to v within B steps.
First of all-- oh, this is bad.
t should not be 1.
This should be B. If B is 1--
let me quickly fix that.
So these t's should be B's.
My apologies.
So if t is 1--
if B is 1, then
they have to-- then
I'm only allowed a
ladder of length 1.
Now I just check
intermediate directly.
Do u and v differ in
just-- in one place?
If yes, then I accept,
else, I reject.
If it's greater than
1, now I'm going
to do this procedure
that I described.
I'm going to try for each
possible w in the middle,
I'm going to try that
w, test whether I
can get from u to w in half
the number of steps and from w
to v in half the
number of steps,
and accept if they both accept.
And if trying all
possible w's, none of them
work, then I know
that there's no way
to get from u to v in B steps.
And so then I reject.
And then to do the original
problem, which was not
the bounded ladder problem, I
do the bounded ladder problem
where I put in t, which is the
maximum possible length that it
could be to get from work to
play or to get from u to v.
So the space analysis--
well, I'm kind of
out of time, here.
So we're going to go through
this again next time.
So let me skip that analysis.
I'll review this next time.
I have a very quick Check-in.
I just want to get here.
Find an English word ladder
that connects the word "must"
to the word "vote."
You can think about that.
I mean, it's not that hard
to come up with such a word
letter, so I encourage you
to think about that-- also,
to think about voting,
which is also important.
That's coming up.
Another 5 seconds here.
I'm going to end
this, so make sure
you get your credit
for the Check-in.
So we're at the
end of the hour--
end of the 80 minutes, anyway.
So this is what we did today.
And looks like I ran over by
a minute, so my apologies.
But I'll stick around
here if any of you
have any further questions.
But otherwise, lecture is over.
See you guys.
Do we know anything about ladder
for other kinds of languages?
I don't know.
Interesting
question, whether you
can say some nice things about
the ladder, the ladder problem,
in other cases.
I don't know.
Why is t here, this value of t?
Sigma to the m, the maximum
length of a word ladder.
First of all, we have the m.
Maybe I should have
written this down. m
is the length of the words.
Sigma is the alphabet
of the words.
So the number of
possible different words
is sigma to the m.
These are all possible words
that there could possibly be.
So there's no reason
in the word ladder ever
to repeat the word because you
can just find a shorter word
ladder that still does
the job of connecting
a start and the end,
because you can just cut out
that middle part,
the repeated part.
So in that case, the
longest possible word
ladder is going to be the
total number of possible words
that you can have, which
is going to be sigma--
the size of sigma to the m.
Explain again why coNP
is a subset of PSPACE.
Well, maybe I'll
say it this way.
Why is it every coNP
language also in PSPACE?
Well, take the complement
of your coNP language.
That's an NP language.
An NP language is in PSPACE
because we proved that.
That's what we proved.
But if a language is in
PSPACE, its complement
is also in PSPACE, because
for a deterministic procedure,
you can just flip the
answer of the machine.
So if B, language B, is in coNP,
its complement, B complement,
is in NP, which is in PSPACE.
So B complement is in PSPACE.
So now PSPACE-- you
can invert the answer.
And now B is also in PSPACE.
I hope that helps.
Somebody's giving me the answer
to get from "must" to "vote."
But I've seen that answer.
There are online tools that
will answer word ladders.
So you just plug in the
start and the finish,
and it'll give you
the word ladder.
And then the one
that this person
has sent me is the one
you get from that tool,
so I suspect he didn't
find it himself.
Before lecture, I actually
solved that on my own,
besides the one that--
I know the one that
the tool will give you.
So that tool gives one
in, I think, five steps.
And I found one on
my own in six steps.
It's not that hard.
Yeah, "must," "most,"
"lost," "lose,"
"rose," "rote," and "vote."
So they made that seven steps.
Anyway, for short words, you
can solve these generally
pretty quickly on your own.
What else?
What else can I do for you?
Do we need to worry
about coming back
to a previously visited word on
the construction on this page?
No, we don't have to
worry about coming back
to a previously visited word.
All you need to worry
about is making sure
that you bound how long
are you going to go for.
And that's where the previously
visited issue comes in.
If the word ladder that you
found repeats some word,
well, then there would have
been a shorter word ladder
that would have also worked.
But it still shows that it's
possible to get from the start
word to the finish word if you
have a repeated one in between.
So that doesn't matter.
We don't have to
worry about that.
If you did, then it
would be problem.
So I think I will--
4:05.
I think I'm going to head out.
See you all, guys.
And I'm going to join my
TAs in a meeting shortly.
So bye-bye.
Thank you for being here.